the bones are good and the dress is
better ladies and gentlemen marin morris
is here
i listen it's been so long since i've
seen a beauty in a gown i just want to
we got to start with the dress who made
this beautiful thing
thank you i'm like overwhelmed at your
kindness um it's
dolce gabbana custom and i just felt
like i
i saw the sketch and it reminded me of
like the roaring 20s and i feel like
we're back in those again so
i was going to kick it off the right way
i mean a hot mama
i would say because we have not seen you
since you became a mom congratulations
thank you let's talk music first though
um
you've been at the grammys before you're
already a grammy winner so does it feel
different to come back and be like okay
pressure's off like i'm good
um i mean the pressure's always there
it's the grammys
but i feel like with my song the bones
it's just had such a
a beautiful journey and to sort of end
it here
um because you know it's sort of the end
of its single cycle
ending at the grammys is a pretty damn
good place to end it
it really is and this song you know i
think a lot of people
realized like all the stuff maybe
doesn't matter
uh and and here you had this like kind
of unconventional pandemic theme song
yeah very unintentional i but i love
that that's my favorite thing is you
know i wrote it about a relationship but
then
so many fans during like the beginning
of kovid were saying
this song reminds me of our world right
now like
when the bones are good the rest don't
matter we're just like in the trenches
together
i love this um john mayer i love this
he's my like one of my favorites
how did the collab come to be i know
same he's amazing i've been such a fan
for a long time but he has really always
been
supportive of me and i think as you know
two musicians
we actually met at the grammys here um a
couple years ago
and then um we've just had this mutual
respect for one another and
our craft at what we do and um when i
got nominated this
year and was going to be performing i
just reached out as a friend
to john and was like hey will you come
and like sit in on guitar
and he graciously said yes and it's just
he's elevated the song
to an even higher level than i i could
have thought
and i'm just so grateful that he said
yes it's so cool
okay chasing after you the new song and
video
i need to talk to you about this you are
a brave woman you put your hot husband
in a silk sheet
shirtless in this video it is st
now everyone gets to enjoy him you're
welcome world yeah we've like
chalked up how many videos ryan's done
with his shirt off at this point and
it's like you know give the people what
they want
um how fun was it though to be on set
together and work together
well this was our first real music video
to do together even like
six years in to this relationship um
we've always written songs we've always
been on stage together but this is our
first time getting to make
visual art and so that was just the most
fun part
and you know it's also like such a
testament to our relationship and you
know being new parents
and getting to just like go at it
together in a video was pretty fun we
were like trying to give it our
our all because it's like when else are
we gonna get to do this it was like get
her a grammy then get her an oscar
because it was like acting like pushing
you away i don't
love you but maybe i do like you know
the circle is going around
vibes very high drama um so they say
that you know having a brand new baby
can be really hard
on a relationship but you guys seem like
you're thriving and i love that you had
some time to kind of be calm during this
so maybe it was a blessing in disguise
oh yeah and my son is actually out here
with me um so this is my first grammys
with a baby
um so things are definitely different
nowadays but no it's definitely changed
us for the better
i think that it just makes you even more
insightful and thoughtful about someone
else's existence outside of your selfish
own needs so
i think that it's just brought us closer
and um we just love that little guy so
much
do you have plans to throw an epic like
first birthday party for haze
well we can't really do super thing but
like yeah we're gonna keep it small
you know just family but i want to do a
peter rabbit theme because
that's the book that we read to him
every night since he was a little
newborn so
i would like to do like carrot cake and
like he's going to have a smash cake and
all the stuff but we'll make it cute but
it's obviously still
not safe to have like a huge brawl but i
i think it's gonna be
adorable does he have any idea like when
you're on the tv
like does he point and he's like does he
understand that mommy is like a glamazon
goddess
a grammy winner he hasn't so far so
maybe the grammys will change the tide i
think you know he's just so confused
even with you know because ryan's back
in nashville
will facetime and hayes will just look
at ryan on facetime and just be so
perplexed and i i can imagine like if
you're a baby you're like what the f
is this but no it's um maybe he'll
recognize me we'll see
okay and last thing i think this is
really cool in the past
maybe there weren't enough female
nominees or female performers and this
year of the grammys just feels like it's
like girl girl girl taylor miranda you
it's got to be radical to be in the
music business right now as a fierce
female to be like
okay ladies like let's go oh yeah and i
think
just the the performances this year are
knocking it out of the park i'm so happy
to be a part of it
i'm excited to see taylor i'm excited to
see dewalippa i'm
so excited to see megan the stallion i
mean i'm just like it's lady love all
[Music]
around